hey this is kind of funny so a while ago
I was contacted by film producer Hillary
and Alexander Bach and they told me hey
we are producing a film and it's an
independent film and we would like to
use some audio of the David Pakman show
because during a certain point in the
film a character is going to be
listening to the radio and the idea is
the David Pakman show
will be playing on the radio and I
thought this is very cool we're breaking
in to film this is the start of an
incredible ascent for the David Pakman
show
may finally made it making cameo
appearances in media and blah blah blah
blah blah so of course I agreed to it
and and we move forward with this and
now I've received a preview of the scene
and I have to admit I'm a little bit
bummed out because you can barely hear
the David Pakman show
over the traffic noise that's part of
the scene and we're gonna play it for
it's only 25 seconds it's during the
opening credits of the film you and me
and I I mean I I don't even know if
you're gonna be able to tell that it's
my voice first you're going to hear that
segment where Donald Trump mocks the
disabled reporter surge Kowalewski and
then it goes to a segment where I am
commenting on that it's a story we did a
while ago one a real story that did
really well on our YouTube channel you
can barely hear it over the traffic
noise but I present to you the
cinematographic debut of the David
Pakman show
poverty is talking about a surge couple
Leske who now works with the New York
Times
-
I you know trace
[Music]
so you might have missed it because it's
almost inaudible but when the character
here if you were just listening was
getting luggage out of her car I am
there commenting and ok well this is it
I hope it was worth it to use the clip
I'm not convinced that the camera guy or
the guy operating the boom didn't just
have the David Pakman show Paul listen
the movie seems absolutely tremendous
and I'm flattered that the clip was used
but what else could we say is this what
faman success feels like if anybody else
has any licensing enquiries you can
reach out to us through our website
david pakman.com